Hallo, Freunde der Sonne!
Ich bin's, Mai,
eure Chemikerin des Vertrauens.
Ich dachte, ich bin die Chemikerin.
- Den Witz hatten wir schon.
Willkommen zu einer neuen Folge:
Kosmetik wissenschaftlich erklärt.
Viele Produkte werden
nicht nur damit beworben,
was sie enthalten, sondern damit,
was sie nicht enthalten.
Wenn wo fett draufsteht
"ohne blablabla",
geht man davon aus,
dass die Abwesenheit
von blablabla was Gutes ist.
Beispiel Nagellackentferner.
Wenn draufsteht "ohne Aceton",
glaubt man, dass Aceton schlecht ist.
Meanwhile, in den USA,
wird Nagellackentferner auch
mit 100 Prozent Aceton beworben.
Da würd man natürlich eher denken:
100 Prozent, nur the good stuff!
Anders gesagt, vieles
was auf einer Verpackung steht,
ist nur Marketing.
Auf welche Inhaltsstoffe
sollte ich wirklich verzichten?
Wir lernen heute,
wie man Inhaltsstoffe liest.
Wir schauen uns drei
"Ohnes" genauer an.
Was steckt dahinter,
wenn auf der Verpackung draufsteht:
ohne Parabene, ohne Silikone,
und ohne Aluminium.
Spoiler: Bei Aluminium gibt es News,
über die kaum gesprochen wurde.
Macht es euch gemütlich, los geht's.
Viele Freunde der Sonne sind auch
Freunde chemischer Strukturformeln.
Aber falls ihr bei chemischen Formeln
so einen leichten bis
mittelschweren Brechreiz empfindet,
bear with me,
es lohnt sich, versprochen.
Starten wir mit:
Parabene sind, wie sag ich das jetzt?
- Warte, darf ich?
Parabene sind die Ester
der para-Hydroxybenzoesäure.
Das ist nicht besonders anschaulich.
- Natürlich.
Das ist Benzoesäure.
Das hier ist die Carbonsäuregruppe
oder nur Säuregruppe.
Und das ist Hydroxybenzoesäure.
Genauer gesagt
para-Hydroxybenzoesäure,
es gibt auch ortho-
und meta-Hydroxybenzoesäure,
je nachdem,
wo diese Hydroxy-Gruppe sitzt.
Das hier ist ein Alkohol,
etwa Ethanol.
Alkohol plus Carbonsäure
minus Wasser ergibt Ester.
Und schon haben wir
para-Hydroxybenzoesäureester,
aka Paraben.
Das sind Chemiebasics.
Das lernt man in der Grundschule.
Da gibt es kein Chemie.
- Was?
Konzentration, bitte.
Es gibt verschiedene Parabene.
Je nach Alkohol gibt es verschiedene
Ester der para-Hydroxybenzoesäure,
die in der Kosmetik verwendet werden:
Methylparaben, Ethylparaben,
Propylparaben und Butylparaben.
Ihr seht, dieses Kohlenstoffkette
wird immer länger.
Parabene haben eine antibakterielle
und antifungale Wirkung.
Das heißt, sie machen Bakterien
und Pilzen das Leben schwer.
Weil sie einfach und günstig
herzustellen sind,
werden sie recht häufig
als Konservierungsstoffe eingesetzt.
In Lebensmitteln, in Medikamenten
und eben auch in Kosmetikartikeln.
Etwa in Lotionen, Shampoos,
Lippenstift oder Mascara.
Bei Lebensmitteln
leuchtet es wahrscheinlich ein,
warum man sie haltbar macht.
Aber auch blumig duftende
Kosmetikartikel,
die geöffnet und ungekühlt
längere Zeit rumstehen,
wären ziemlich pfui
ohne Schimmelschutz.
Je länger diese Seitenkette ist,
desto stärker ist
die antibakterielle Wirkung.
Allerdings nimmt gleichzeitig die
Wasserlöslichkeit in die Richtung ab.
Denn solche Kohlenstoffketten
verstehen sich nicht gut mit Wasser.
Sie sind hydrophob,
wörtlich: wasserhassend.
Je länger die Kohlenstoffkette,
desto hydrophober.
Fette und Öle etwa
bestehen hauptsächlich
aus langen Kohlenstoffketten.
Die sind gar nicht wasserlöslich
oder mit Wasser mischbar.
Kosmetikartikel bestehen oft
zum größten Teil aus Wasser.
Wenn ihr auf
die Inhaltsstoffliste schaut,
ist der erste Eintrag
meistens Aqua, also Wasser.
Die Reihenfolge der Inhaltsstoffe
richtet sich, wie bei Lebensmitteln,
nach der Menge.
Wasser ist genau das, was
Mikroorganismen brauchen,
wo sich sich vermehren.
Deswegen haben verschiedene Parabene
Vor- und Nachteile
bezüglich ihrer
antibakteriellen Stärke
und ihrer Wasserlöslichkeit.
Laut Verordnung
der Europäischen Kommission
ist die Maximalkonzentration
0,4 Prozent bei einem Paraben
beziehungsweise 0,8 Prozent
bei Parabengemischen.
Viel ist das also ohnehin nicht.
Was veranlasst also
Hersteller und Kunden,
ganz auf Parabene zu verzichten?
Ein Grund für die Abneigung:
Parabene gelangen
über die Kosmetik in den Körper.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das
eher überrascht oder eben nicht.
Manche haben vielleicht
generell Angst,
dass alles über die Haut
in den Körper gelangt.
Andere glauben eher,
solange man es nicht
schluckt oder einatmet,
alles safe ist.
Man kann das so pauschal nicht sagen.
Die Haut ist prinzipiell
schon eine gute Schutzbarriere,
aber es gibt Stoffe,
die aufgenommen werden können,
Parabene gehören dazu.
Je länger diese Seitenkette ist,
desto leichter wird das Paraben
von der Haut aufgenommen.
Aber nur weil etwas
in den Körper gelangt,
heißt das nicht automatisch,
dass es auch schädlich ist.
Man kann Parabene im Urin nachweisen.
Das heißt erst mal nur,
dass wir sie wieder ausscheiden.
Was erst mal gut ist.
Es gibt aber einen Verdacht,
der Parabenen
einen schlechten Ruf verleiht,
nämlich dass sie
sein könnten.
Also Substanzen,
die auf schädliche Weise
in den Hormonhaushalt
des Körpers eingreifen.
Der Verdacht stützt sich
auf einen plausiblen Mechanismus:
nämlich dass sie anbinden an:
Östrogene gehören
zu den Sexualhormonen,
also wie alle Hormone
haben sie viele Funktionen,
etwa bei der Knochenbildung
oder im Stoffwechsel.
Vor allem sind Östrogene
für die Geschlechtsreife
bei Mädchen und Frauen zuständig.
In Laborversuchen mit Zellen,
also in vitro,
wurde so eine östrogene Wirkung
von Parabenen tatsächlich beobachtet.
Und zwar, umso stärker,
je länger die Seitenkette.
Doch in vivo,
also in Tierversuchen,
gab es bisher
uneinheitliche Ergebnisse.
Und Ergebnisse aus Tierversuchen
lassen ohnehin nur bedingt
auf Menschen übertragen.
Wie bei vielen
potenziell schädlichen Stoffen
ist es oft nicht ethisch vertretbar,
systematische Studien
an Menschen durchzuführen.
Man kann stattdessen
Beobachtungsstudien machen,
die waren bisher aber so mittelgut.
Beispiel.
In dieser Studie wurden 264 Kinder
beziehungsweise Heranwachsende
ab einem Alter von neun Jahren
über mehrere Jahre begleitet.
Man hat unter anderem beobachtet,
wann bei ihnen die Pubertät einsetzt
und wie viele Parabene sie
im Urin haben.
Dabei zeigte sich
folgender Zusammenhang:
Bei Mädchen
mit einer höheren Konzentration
von Methylparaben im Urin,
setzten auch bestimmte Anzeichen
der Pubertät früher ein.
Nämlich die erste Periode,
das Auftreten von Schamhaaren
und das Wachstum der Brüste.
Heißt das, dass Parabene
zu einer früheren Pubertät führen?
Nein, es kann auch
genau andersrum sein:
Dass Mädchen,
die früher in die Pubertät kommen,
früher mehr Kosmetik benutzen und
deswegen mehr Parabene im Urin haben.
Außerdem betonten
die Autoren dieser Studie auch,
dass sie die Teilnehmer
zwar über Jahre beobachtet haben,
währenddessen aber nur zwei-, dreimal
Urinproben genommen haben.
Wenn Parabene sehr schnell
wieder ausgespült werden,
hat es nicht große Aussagekraft.
Es gibt ein aktuelles Review,
das 2020 veröffentlicht wurde.
Hier hat man sich angeschaut,
wie viele Parabene
tatsächlich in
verschieden Produkten enthalten sind,
wie viel davon dann auch tatsächlich
über die Haut in den Körper gelangt.
und welche Höchstmengen
verschiedene Studien
noch als harmlos befunden haben.
Unterm Strich kommt
die Autorin zu dem Ergebnis,
dass einzelne Kosmetikprodukte
mit Parabenen
der besten Kenntnis nach
kein Risiko darstellen.
Aber es ist nicht ausgeschlossen,
dass manche Menschen
so viele unterschiedliche
parabenhaltige Produkte benutzen,
dass es dadurch doch zu einem
Gesundheitsrisiko kommen könnte.
Also, gelangen Parabene
in den Körper? Ja.
Werden sie auch wieder ausgeschieden?
Ja.
Können sie an den
Estrogenrezeptor binden? Ja.
Richtet das Schäden an?
In diesen kleinen Mengen
wahrscheinlich nicht.
Hinzu kommt, dass die östrogene
Wirkung von Parabenen
in bisherigen Studien
deutlich schwächer war,
als bei körpereigenem Östrogen.
Aber, wenn man sehr oft sehr viel
parabenhaltige Produkte benutzt,
ist es nicht auszuschließen,
dass eine bedenkliche Dosis
erreicht werden könnte.
Unsere Funk-Kollegen von "STRG_F"
haben in ihrem neuesten Video
einen Parfum-Selbsttest gemacht,
mit Urinproben, unter anderem
auch mit einem Urin-Fail.
Aber ich will nicht zu viel verraten.
Schaut am besten selbst vorbei.
Parabene sind
ein klassisches Beispiel
für eine unbefriedigende Datenlage.
Natürlich hätte man lieber
ein klares Ja oder Nein.
In die Praxis übersetzt heißt das,
wie so oft:
Am besten alles in Maßen.
Deutlich ist die Lage allerdings bei
Silikone werden
kosmetisch viel genutzt,
berühmterweise
in der kosmetischen Chirurgie
und das möglicherweise zunehmend,
denn während bis zu den 90ern
es vor allem Brustimplantate waren,
sind inzwischen auch
Poimplantate beliebt.
Wir wissen alle: "My anaconda don't
want none, unless you got buns hun".
In Shampoos und Haarspülungen
werden Silikone eingesetzt als
Sie verleihen dem Haar
Glanz und Geschmeidigkeit.
Auch wenn es andere
Conditioners gibt außer Silikon,
haben Silikone, meiner Meinung nach,
mit Abstand den besten
Conditioning-Effekt.
Trotzdem werden Shampoos und
Spülungen zunehmen damit beworben,
silikonfrei zu sein.
Meistens werden Silikone
unter dem Label Chemie gehandelt,
also ohne Silikone und ohne Chemie
wird oft im selben Satz genannt.
Was für eine (Piepton).
- Ja.
Das eigentliche Silikon
ist natürlich nicht,
dass sie chemisch sind,
was korrekterweise heißen müsste,
dass sie künstlich hergestellt sind.
Aber ob etwas künstlich hergestellt
wurde oder natürlichen Ursprungs ist,
sagt nichts darüber aus,
welche Eigenschaften
dieser Stoff hat.
Die Eigenschaften eines Stoffes,
natürlich wie künstlich,
ergeben sich
aus der chemischen Struktur.
Das ist dein Cue.
- Ich hab keine Lust mehr.
Silikone sind Polysiloxane,
oder auch Polyorganosiloxane.
Die Vorsilbe "poly" bedeutet,
dass Silikone Polymere sind.
Das heißt, langkettige Moleküle.
Das Backbone dieser langen Kette
besteht aus abwechselnden
Silicium- und Sauerstoffatomen.
Am Siliciumatom hängen außerdem noch
sogenannte organische Reste,
also Kohlenstoffgruppen,
daher auch "organo".
Sehr gängig sind
zwei sogenannte Methylgruppen,
das sind dann solche CH3-Gruppen.
Dann heißt dieses Silikon
Polydimethylsiloxan.
Ein anderer Name ist Dimeticon.
Auf der Inhaltsstoffliste
findet ihr Silikone
unter Siloxan und Dimeticon.
Am häufigsten eingesetzt werden
zyklische Silikone
verschiedener Größe.
Cyclotetrasiloxan, Cyclopentasiloxan
und Cyclohexasiloxan,
die auch mit D4, D5 und D6
abgekürzt werden.
Nicht zu verwechseln
mit homöopathischen Potenzen.
Die Silicium-Sauerstoffbindungen
sind relativ flexibel.
Wenn das die Bindungen sind zwischen
Sauerstoff, Silicium, Sauerstoff,
dann ist dieser Bindungswinkel
relativ flexibel und variabel.
Außerdem können sich
diese Methylgruppen frei drehen,
auch entlang der Kette
kann sich das Molekül drehen.
Diese allgemeine Beweglichkeit
in der chemischen Struktur
sorgt für die charakteristischen
Eigenschaften von Silikonen:
sie sind weiche, elastische,
flexible Materialien.
Obwohl Silikone schon in den 40ern
zum ersten Mal
in einer Bodylotion verwendet wurden,
war ihr Einsatz lange beschränkt,
weil sie in Wasser unlöslich sind.
Normalerweise sind
wasserunlösliche Sachen
dann wenigstens öllöslich.
Selbst in Öl oder anderen
gängigen organischen Lösungsmitteln
sind Silikone auch nicht
besonders geil löslich.
Also Silikone sind generell
ziemlich schlecht löslich.
Und das ist ein Problem.
Wenn man dann versucht,
Silikone in Shampoo reinzumischen,
wird das nur klumpig
oder setzt sich am Boden ab.
So kriegt man das nicht aufs Haar.
Um sich Klumpen
in die Haare zu schmieren,
ist ein
Roggenmehl-Shampoo zu empfehlen.
Was dann kein Shampoo ist,
"No Poo-Methode",
dazu haben wir mal ein Video gemacht.
Findet ihr in der Infocard.
Es ist den meisten
wahrscheinlich nicht bewusst,
aber die Inhaltsstoffe
für etwa ein Shampoo herzustellen,
das ist die eine Sache.
Diese Inhaltsstoffe
erfolgreich zusammenzubringen,
also zusammenzumischen,
ist überhaupt nicht trivial.
Weil das Ganze im Zweifelsfall
zu fest, zu flüssig, zu schaumig,
zu wenig schaumig wird.
Oder weil es nicht stabil ist,
die Mischung.
Ein gutes Shampoo zusammenzumischen
ist eine Kunst.
Es ist eine Wissenschaft!
Es ist eine Fachspezialisierung
der Chemie namens:
Das heißt,
Silikone sind zwar unlöslich,
aber sie sind formulierbar.
Also durch chemische
Modifizierung der Silikone
und durch den Einsatz bestimmter
Lösungsmitte und Tenside,
kann man die Silikone
innerhalb der Shampoo-Formulierung
stabilisieren.
Wenn man sich
mit dem Shampoo die Haare wäscht,
dann wird die perfekt
abgestimmte Formulierung
durch das Duschwasser verdünnt.
Anders: Die Formulierung
wird zerstört.
Die Silikone werden also
durch die Verdünnung
von den stabilisierenden
Zusätzen getrennt,
und machen in der Folge das,
was unlösliche Substanzen machen,
sie setzen sich ab
und zwar auf dem Haar.
Dort bleiben sie auch, trotz duschen,
weil sie wasserunlöslich sind.
Das ist auch der Witz, die Silikone
bilden auf dem Haar einen Film,
der auch besonders
gleichmäßig und glatt ist
und das Licht besser reflektiert,
als da nackte Haar.
Deswegen der Glanz.
Außerdem sorgt
die glatte Beschichtung
für den Conditioning-Effekt,
bessere Kämmbar- und Geschmeidigkeit.
Ihr habt bestimmt mal Mikroskopie-
Aufnahmen von Haaren gesehen,
die haben Schuppen,
oder sie können auch splissig sein.
Das wird versiegelt
durch die Silikone.
Gleichzeitig führt das
zu dem eigentlichen Problem,
nämlich weil Silikone
schlecht löslich sind,
wird man sie auch
schlecht wieder los.
Natürlich hilft das auch
das physikalische Reiben dabei,
das Zeug nach und nach loszuwerden,
aber prinzipiell lassen sich
Silikonen sehr schlecht auswaschen.
Wenn man jetzt jeden Tag
oder bei jeder Haarwäsche
silikonhaltige Produkte benutzt,
kommt es zu einem
Durch den Build-Up
werden die Haare mit der Zeit
schwer, ölig, fettig, schlapp.
Weswegen es sinnvoll ist,
Shampoos und Spülungen
auch ohne Silikone zu verkaufen.
Wobei ich sagen muss:
Ohne Silikone?
Ich will aber Silikon.
Ich hab ziemlich dicke,
asiatische Haare,
die aber auch relativ
trocken und spröde sind.
Also ich benutze sehr gerne
silikonhaltige Spülungen,
auch wenn ich sie mir nicht
auf den Ansatz mache,
sondern nur ab hier reinschmiere.
Aber ich find es gut,
dass Silikone das Haar beschweren.
Wie gesagt:
Es sind die besten Conditioner.
Wer aber feine
oder leicht fettende Haare hat,
sollte auf Silikone verzichten.
Was passiert mit den Silikonen,
nachdem sie den Abfluss
hinuntergespült wurden?
Weil sie so schlecht löslich sind,
setzt sich fast alles im Klärschlamm,
im festen Abfall
der Kläranlagen, ab.
Silikone, die in der Umwelt landen,
sei es in Böden oder Mülldeponien,
zersetzen sich unter sauren
oder basischen Bedingungen ganz gut.
Davon abgesehen,
sind sie relativ
Das bedeutet, sie gehen kaum
chemische Reaktionen ein.
Sind also auch schlecht abbaubar.
Also auch da gibt es
gewissermaßen ein Build-Up.
Es gibt allerdings
wenig Hinweise darauf,
dass Silikone
Mikroorganismen oder Tieren,
die damit
in Berührung kommen, schaden.
Zusammengefasst, wer feines
oder fettiges Haar hat,
sollte auf Silikone verzichten,
davon abgesehen,
sind sie eher unbedenklich.
Moving on:
Ohne Aluminium sind viele Deos.
Wobei Deos eigentlich ja
sowieso kein Aluminium enthalten.
Das was wir umgangssprachlich
als Deos bezeichnen,
umfasst eigentlich
zwei verschiedene Dinge:
erstens Deodorantien.
und zweitens Antitranspirantien.
Deodorantien
helfen nicht gegen Schweiß.
Sie sorgen nur dafür,
dass der Schweiß nicht stinkt.
Erstens mit Parfümen und zweitens
mit antibakteriellen Stoffen,
etwa Triclosan.
Eigentlich ist nicht
der Schweiß das Problem.
Schweiß an sich ist geruchlos.
Das Problem sind Bakterien
in unseren Achselhöhlen,
die sich von dem Schweiß
oder den Proteinen darin, ernähren
und dabei Stoffwechselprodukte
erzeugen, die stinken nach Schweiß.
Antitranspirantien hingegen
hemmen wirklich das Schwitzen.
Und zwar mithilfe von Aluminium.
Genauer gesagt,
Aluminiumsalze wie Aluminiumchlorid
oder Aluminiumhydroxychlorid.
Wenn diese Aluminiumsalze auf
Proteine in unserem Schweiß treffen,
bilden sie unlösliche
Flocken, Pfropfen, Stopfen,
die unsere Schweißporen verstopfen.
Dieses Bilden
unlöslicher Ablagerungen nennt man
Die Alusalze fällen Proteine aus,
sagt man.
Übrigens gibt es auch
solche Natur-Kristall-Deos,
die sehr gute
Antitranspirantien sind,
weil sie zu 100 Prozent
aus Aluminiumsalzen bestehen.
Das sind zwar
andere Aluminiumsalze als die im Deo,
was aber auch egal ist,
weil das Aluminium das Problem ist
und nicht der Rest des Salzes.
So viel zu der Logik hinter
Naturkosmetik ohne Chemie.
Ich sagt doch (Piepton).
Ich find es generell
eine sehr unangenehme Vorstellung
so verstopfte Schweißporen,
zumal schwitzen ja auch eine sehr
effiziente Art der Abkühlung ist,
um die uns einige Tiere
sehr beneiden würden.
Kängurus lecken sich
in der australischen Hitze
die Unterarme ab,
um durch das Verdunsten
des Speichels abzukühlen.
Die würden uns auslachen,
wenn die wüssten,
dass wir uns freiwillig
unsere Schweißporen verstopfen.
Wo war ich?
- Aluminium.
Obwohl Aluminium
ein sehr häufiges Element ist
und wir es deswegen
täglich zu uns nehmen,
übers Essen, Trinken, ja sogar
in kleinen Mengen über die Luft,
die wir einatmen,
ist Aluminium ab einer gewissen Dosis
gesundheitsschädlich.
Sehr hohe Dosen führen
zu einer Aluminiumvergiftung,
bei der unter anderem Knochen
oder Gehirn geschädigt werden können.
Einige erforschen den Verdacht,
dass schon kleinere Mengen
das Risiko für
bestimmte Krankheiten erhöhen könnte,
zum Beispiel Krebs oder Alzheimer.
Allerdings gibt es dazu bisher
keine überzeugenden Hinweise.
Es ist ein klassischer Fall von
"die Dosis macht das Gift".
Es gibt den empfohlenen Höchstwert
von einem Milligramm
pro Kilogramm Körpergewicht
und Woche.
Das BfR, also das
Bundesinstitut für Risikobewertung,
rät, Aluminiumquellen zu vermeiden,
wenn es denn geht.
Denn einige Lebensmittel enthalten
auch schon so Aluminium.
Zum Beispiel einige Getreidesorten,
Miesmuscheln oder Tee.
(Anschwellender Ton)
Ist auch kein Problem,
solange man nichts anderes macht,
als nur "maiLab" zu schauen
und dabei pausenlos Tee zu trinken.
Trotzdem sollte man darauf achten,
sein Essen nicht zu lange
in Aluschalen warmzuhalten.
Besonders leicht löst sich Aluminium
in Kontakt mit Salz oder Säure.
Also man sollte jetzt nicht
eine Zitrone über Alufolie
ausdrücken und trinken.
Ach, menno!
Außerdem sollte man laut BfR
nicht nur beim Essen aufpassen,
sondern auch sparsam
mit Antitranspirantien umgehen.
Ich denk grad an Männerdeo-Werbung,
wo sich die Männer so kreuzweise
den ganzen Oberkörper einsprühen.
Macht das irgendjemand wirklich?
Schreibt in die Kommentare.
Jedenfalls, in der Stellungname
vom BfR vom November 2019,
also ganz aktuell,
wurde noch dazu geraten, sparsam
mit Antitranspirantien umzugehen.
Aber eigentlich war
die Datenlage zu Aluminium
bisher noch nie
so richtig alarmierend.
Aber auch nicht so richtig klar,
dass man immer wieder lesen konnte:
Es wird gerade noch
genauer erforscht, stay tunded.
Was soll ich sagen,
Freunde der Sonne?
Das "Tunded-Bleiben"
hat sich gelohnt,
denn tatsächlich gab es diesen März
große News aus der Aluforschung.
So wurde eine neue Stellungnahme,
basierend auf neuen Studien-
ergebnissen, veröffentlicht vom SCCS,
dem Wissenschaftliche Ausschuss
Verbrauchersicherheit der EU.
Nun ist diese Stellungnahem
diesen März
ein bisschen untergegangen.
Die Menschen hatten diesen März
irgendwie andere Prioritäten,
als neue Antitranspirantienforschung.
Dabei hat das Ergebnis
der Stellungnahme
durchaus Aufmerksamkeit verdient.
Denn der SCCS kommt durch
die neuen Studien zu dem Schluss,
im Vergleich zu
Aluminiumaufnahme durch die Nahrung
macht es keinen Unterschied,
welches Deo ich benutze.
Mengen, die durch Deos oder Kosmetik
tatsächlich aufgenommen werden,
haben sich jetzt
als vernachlässigbar herausgestellt.
Das ist also ganz anders als das,
was noch im November
vom BfR veröffentlicht wurde.
Ich hatte mich ziemlich gewundert,
als Ende letzten Jahres
das BfR noch mal groß gewarnt hat
vor einer möglichen Gefahr
durch Alu in Kosmetiker,
obwohl damals ja
diese EU-Studie im Abschluss war,
und die Ergebnisse
noch nicht vorgelegen haben.
Das ist Hinnerk Feldwisch-Drentrup.
Wobei korrekterweise:
Feldwisch genannt Drentrup,
ein Wissenschaftsjournalist
mit kompliziertem Namen.
Das Institut ist jetzt
in einer Zwickmühle,
denn, wie sich rausgestellt hat,
beruhten seine Warnungen
teils auf falschen Annahmen.
Es müsste diese
korrigieren oder zurückziehen.
Aber was einmal in der Welt ist,
lässt sich nicht
so leicht richtigstellen.
Das Ganze hat zu einer Verunsicherung
der Verbraucher beigetragen.
Hinnerk ist Mitgründer
des Onlinemagazins "MedWatch".
Mit seiner Kollegin recherchiert er
zu Falschinfos
aus dem Gesundheitsbereich.
Hier stellt er nicht nur
die neuesten Studienergebnisse vor,
sondern fragt auch beim BfR nach,
ob sie jetzt
ihre Warnung zurücknehmen,
und bei den Herstellern,
ob sie weiter mit
"Ohne Aluminium" werben wollen.
Wenn ihr gern "maiLab" schaut,
wird euch auch "MedWatch" gefallen.
Ich hab euch den Artikel verlinkt,
schaut da nachher unbedingt vorbei.
Vor allem, wenn ihr euch fragt:
Hab ich die letzten Jahre
umsonst alufreies Deo benutzt
und wie ein Schwein geschwitzt?
Wobei Schweine kaum schwitzen können.
Ich hab immer zwei Deos zu Hause,
eins mit und eins ohne Aluminium.
Ich schwitze nicht so viel
und ich finde
Antitranspirantien eher unangenehm,
das macht meine Achseln so trocken,
dass es fast juckt.
Ich benutze die nur
aus optischen Gründen,
wenn ich Schweißflecken
unbedingt vermeiden möchte,
wie heute zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Ansonsten nutze ich nur normale Deos.
Aber ich wär ohnehin mal dafür,
dass wir Schweißflecken endlich mal
gesellschaftlich akzeptieren,
solange wir alle dafür sorgen,
dass wir uns nicht anstinken.
Das ist doch die Hauptsache?
Müssen wir uns echt
die Schweißporen verstopfen?
Ansonsten schreibt gerne
in die Kommentare,
über welche Kosmetikartikel
oder Inhaltstoffe
ich in Zukunft was machen soll.
Ich verlink euch noch
mein Video über Mizellenwasser.
In dem lernt ihr, wie ihr das
perfekte Reinigungsprodukt findet,
nicht anhand der Claims
auf der Verpackung,
sondern anhand der Inhaltsstoffliste.
Ich verlink euch noch mal
das Video von "STRG_F",
die übrigens den Grimme Online Award
gewonnen haben.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch
und vergesst nicht,
bei Hinnek und "MedWatch"
vorbeizuschauen.
So ist der Tag schon rum
und ihr seid viel schlauer.
Bis in zwei Wochen, bleibt sicher.